to Larry Barton for the pioneering
design development and engineering and
to Ben Wilcox for the electronic
engineering and software development of
cinematography electronic synotape the
academy presents a scientific and
Engineering award to Ben and Larry
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you wow
thank you so much for this honor
this is an incredible moment for all of
us at cinematography Electronics
I would like to introduce and
acknowledge the city tape development
team
Ben Wilcox
Chris niehaus and Thomas Barton who are
in the audience
[Applause]
City tape wouldn't be the same without
you guys
your incredible software tweaks
mechanical fixes
and app shortcuts
made it work
my heartfelt thanks to my wife Lillian
who's also in the audience
and my family for your love and support
throughout this journey
and the focus pullers thank you to all
the focus pullers and Camera Crews
around the world
who supported
and trusted
the cine tape
for 22 years
and lastly thanks to the academy and
scitec committees
that have made this award possible
I am humbled and grateful thank you
[Applause]
I would like to thank the academy for
this award
it's nice to have your work recognized
by other people than your co-workers
also I would like to thank my co-workers
who helped who helped get things built
repaired and shipped out the door
that thinks Pam and Chris and the others
at cinematography electronics and last I
would like to thank Larry Barton
for hiring me so many many years ago
which got me working in this industry
thanks
[Applause]